You
Hi
Can you hear me? Can you hear me, okay?
My mic's not being like extremely bad this time
Not so good. I'm so happy
B&U kinda loud, I heard that I got you
What's up? Welcome in everyone from from M.A.S.
M.A.S. Dream. Have you all enjoyed M.A.S. Dream?
Hello hello
I can do louder
Okay
Yay! Am I right? Am I right?
Hi, welcome in everyone
And it was Nia's
What are you guys there for?
Stronius and Shavius and IcyStream too?
I hope you are
Thank you
My mic sounds better now, yay!
I'm so happy, I'm glad
I made a mistake
It was like a big mistake last time
I'm so sorry
I swear to you, I was checking
All my audio
I was checking my audio yesterday before that
The day before that
And just before I went live
And then all of a sudden
It was bad, it was so bad
I was so loud
Beating in your ear
I'm so happy, it sounds so much better
Music is loud, my queen
What? I just turned it down
Okay, I got you, I'll turn it down some more
Cheers
Is that good?
Is it better?
I pray
Power of God
Good, good
And
I know it's impossible to stream without scuff
It happens, it comes
It comes and it goes
You have another choice
What to do?
Get through it
It's like the voice
I'm mercy
I'm chibi
I'm mercy chibi
I'm so like
My throat is so dry
I feel sick
It's cold
It's nice and cold
Much better
My throat is almost better
Yeah, I'm hydrating with milk
Nice fresh milk
Yeah
I wouldn't be surprised
if there are some of you already falling asleep
If you find my voice super
You know
Relaxing to that point
of falling asleep
I understand
Come closer to the mic
Actually, I think I'll turn it up a little bit
Cause I did turn it down
quite a bit
So scared that I'd be too loud
Hang on, whoop, I made a mistake
Uh
Is this better?
Let me know
Is this good?
Can you hear me?
Sounds good
Yes
Good audio?
Sounds good
Better
I heard solution
Silly
I love this
There we go
What, alright
We'll get this down
Trust, we'll get this down
And we won't have to worry about this cup anymore
Well
Here's eventually
Are you nervous?
Me?
Maybe
Maybe a little bit
I'm a little nervous
I'm a big brave
I'm a big brave woman, alright
A lot of big brave women
Alright, okay
I was just setting everything up
And I thought we'd just, you know, relax
And chill and talk about
The day veiled in some of my interests
And stuff that
I went over
I didn't really get to list everything
That I had on there
Sadly, because I thought that
It would just be better just to list like ten things
Five things
And not like crowded with so much stuff
So
I had
Just a few things
And I do want to go over some of the entrusts
Especially anime choices
And some really big game choices
And stuff, and some more stuff I want to talk about
So if you guys have any questions for me
I'll be happy to
Go over some questions that you have for me
I also want to go over some morals
And talk about
Some things that just came out
Today
Yay
Blessed with the legendary voice
I heard a lot of people tell me that
She can't keep up that voice
It's impossible
I want to say that this is
This is actually my voice
So I don't know
I have quite a range
In my voice
So I can change the voice
But this is my natural voice
So yeah
Can you do impressions too?
There is one impression that I think I can't do
But I don't want to
Because I don't have confidence in it
But I used to do a really good Cartman voice
For self perk
I can't hear it
I'm like so nervous
I'm kind of messing up with a bunch of it
I'm so scared
It's that
It's the Cartman voice
And the goofy voice that I can do
It's like the only impressions that I ever did
When I get really excited or bored
Or having fun or playing games and stuff
I'll probably do them randomly out of the blue
It's like a... how do you call it?
Stimulize? Stimulation?
People do random sounds and noises
Every now and then
You'll probably hear me do it out of the blue
Cartman voice line and goofy teaser please
Yes gamer, I get my girl
This is true
Cartman ASMR win
Oh my god
That's hilarious
That sounds like fun
I get me and ASMR, I would love to do that
I probably wouldn't be able to get through it
I'd laugh the entire time
I wouldn't be able to stop laughing
I can't even imagine doing a goofy ASMR
Oh god, that sounds amazing
That sounds so awesome
You?
I can't do it
My body just won't let me
Oh my god
Oh man, okay
I have like bad like
I have like ADHD right?
I would weekend end up sitting here talking for like
For hours
And I'd forget everything else that I'm supposed to be doing
So let's make sure we stay on track
Okay
Chatting is the best thing
It is, I enjoy it a lot
I still want to get through a lot of stuff
I don't want to get too distracted
But I do like talking to you guys a lot
Like seeing what you guys have to say
And your questions
And you guys get to know me as me
I am still Azura, but yeah
Professional Yapper, yeah
Totally professional
I'm sorry I needed more water
You know when you talk a lot
You gotta drink a lot of water
A lot, a lot, a lot of water
Don't stop water
Okay
I want you to do this
And
Okay, hang on
Plop, plop, plop, plop, plop, plop, plop
What do I click?
Where are we?
I still just see him
I did it
I figured it out
Oh no, that's not supposed to be on screen yet
Oh no
That's fine, that's pretend
That everything is fine
Everything is perfectly fine
Just like this
This is how it's supposed to have been
It was like this from the start
Ever from the start
That's right, you saw nothing
You saw nothing
Only mommy
Only me, you only saw me
No one else
Nothing else
Okay
Alright
I'm on it
I worried so like
I was like
When I set up these slides
I swear
I thought it was super fun
I was looking up these collars
To look like a little milk
Like animation
I wanted this little animation to be like
Milk
So I didn't know
How to like
Do it
So I did the little waves
And I like searched it up
Like how to do the waves
I'm not really good with the technical stuff
When it comes to these kind of things
But I really don't
I really do like looking into it
And so I was like
I want milk
I want it to be on the background
So I thought it was like really cool
Okay
So I thought that was Zura
I just wanted to add that
So I did want to go over
My interest
And I mentioned
That I watch a lot of anime
But
When I said a lot of anime
And I said a thousand anime
I really meant it
Like I've actually
When I was younger
I used to
Make a list
Like I would
I had a book
I still have it
Like a notebook
Where I wrote down
Every anime I finished
I would write down
And I got up to
A thousand seven hundred
And then I
I just stopped
Writing down anime
After that
So the threshold
Of how much anime
I've watched in between there
And then and there
Was
Probably in like
Two thousand four hundred now
Does Azul like
Overlord?
Yes!
I've watched Overlord
Do I like Re Zero?
Yes! I've watched Re Zero
I
Thoughts on
Reincarnation
To the slime season
I'm actually
Kind of a little bit
Disappointed
In the
The new season
Because
It was like
They spent like
Six episodes
I'm over exaggerating
They spent so many episodes just talking
Talking
And I'm up to date
So you have to wait a week
For the next episode
Only for them to
Talk more
Then they're like
Oh there's going to be a fight
In the next episode
More talking
They spent
Those episodes
Literally at the same table
The same table
The same scene
All they did was switch seats
And then when the
Big scene came
I won't spoil it
For anyone who's watching
Won't spoil it
Then when the big scene came
The big big major scene
Where you know
The big stuff was going to happen
Literally they
They like separate it and was like
Yeah let's
Me and you pair up
Yeah how about we go over here
How about we go over here
Then they don't even show it
They don't even show the fight
They don't even show it
We don't even get to see
Each character fight
Yeah I was disappointed
I was disappointed
Animation's still good
But I was very disappointed
I finally
Kept up
What other animals
Yes I've watched TVZ
I've watched the big threes
I've watched the big fives
I've watched all the big ones
Really famous ones
100%
I'm a big Naruto fan
I've watched it
For the whole 15 years
Of Naruto
So I'm a huge Naruto fan
I have all the games
I've had all the games
Someone stole two of my games
But we won't
We'll talk about that
I am not a fan of
Naruto
I'm sorry
I know a lot of people like
Naruto
But I'm not a fan of
I don't like
I don't like that child
Though I still watch it
Because I'm still a fan
Of the series itself
I have to watch it
I cannot not watch it
Naruto made me angry
It's like
I've been with Naruto
For so long
That I understand
His pain
What he had to do
To get to where he was
And he doesn't understand
The concept of being a parent
And I understand
Naruto
Needing a parent by him
But
And I understand he's still a kid
And he can't understand
This concept
Of what Naruto went through
But they're hiding it from him
And it made it a little worse
Like just tell the kid
Tell him
Tell him what happened
So that he could finally understand
And mature
And stop being a brat
It's such a brat
Well of course
My favorite character
Is Hinata
Sorry
It's my boo-dang
I love Hinata
It's Hinata and Rock Lee
I really like Rock Lee
Like come on
A character that worked
Really really hard
To get where he is
And to be
At the top of where everyone is
Like come on
It's Rock Lee
And guys and Zebra
I like them
Oh man
You guys have so much less
Of a
More anime
More questions
But other anime
I'm trying to keep up
I'm so not used to
This chat movement so fast
I
Yeah
Rock Lee vs. Gar was the best fight
Whenever
Little
It was a great fight
Hype was crazy
Uncle bad
Get very cute
I like Uncle too
I
Had to raise Zebra
I know you're pissed
I watched so many more anime
I watched Yu Yu Hakusho
I watched all the old old anime
Dang
I watched Inuyasha
I think Inuyasha was like
What
Like really got me into anime
A long time ago
Since
Way back when
I used to be a poor poor child
I still am
Didn't have a TV
Didn't have anything
So
When I went to go visit
Family
I would stay over
And they had a TV
And it would stay on all night
And I would sleep
And watching cartoons
Cartoons
And
You fall asleep
And in the middle of the night
You know
The ending would play
And
And it would wake me up
And then I would sit there
And I would watch it
Like
And then I'd end up watching
You Know Yasha
And then after that
I really got into watching
You Know Yasha
And then I started watching
More anime
And more
I was watching
The Big O
Cowboy Bebop
All of this came on
On Adult Swem
I was watching all of these
On the TV
I definitely shouldn't
Have been watching these things
Given how old I was then
But I was watching all of them
I remember
When I first watched
Caster & Sins
It was a
Thanksgiving day
And
They turned on the TV
To keep the
Kitties distracted
And
They knew I liked anime
But they didn't know
What anime was really about
So they just turned it on
The TV
And Caster & Sins
Like a marathon was running
And I watched the whole thing
While I was sitting there
On the floor
Like
Wah
That's crazy
It's like a
Whole marathon
Are you watching the new
Spice & Wolf?
It's on my
To watch list
I really enjoyed
The first
Spice & Wolf
The original
Before they did the remake
I really
I watched the whole thing
And I know the whole song
Seven apples on a
Witch's tree
With seven seas
A plant inside of me
And springtime
I sing
A magic song
Then skipping along
I sing
A song to everyone
I look at the world
Through
Apple eyes
I cut myself a slice
Of sunshine pie
I know that whole song
So I have it on my
To watch list
I was waiting
For all the episodes
To come out
So it's on my list
To watch the
New Spice & Wolf
Any guilty pleasure
Animated
Ease
Like
An anime that's trash
But you can't get enough
None that I could
Think of
I don't think
I could think
Of one right now
I know a
Bunch of anime
That has
Like really bad animation
But the plot
Is so funny
So I still like it
Or like
It's chaotic
like childish anime that I really like it was an anime that I used to watch when I
was younger called Kadocha Kadocha was like a little girl named like was it
Sonako? Sonako? She would sing into this toy.
Super old anime so old no one knows of it but it was so funny to me it was
hilarious to me I found it very funny a lot of people would probably watch it
now I'd be like what the hell sounds horrible this looks terrible
I do like Belle's above 100% it's a good it's a good anime I really love
anime is that um that have delinquents in it I love delinquency
delinquency anime is so good I just love their voice
I just like the way they talk and the way they yell at each other it's my
favorite so one or there is a delinquent in an anime they're like usually my
favorite favorite characters and yes I watched I shield 21 as well I really
like sports anime as well so I put blue lock because it was like one of the
newest like recent ones that I've watched and I like I like when they're
really suspenseful and I think blue lock really hit that like I've been
craving a sports anime with really good animation that is really suspenseful for
a while and then with blue lock came out it was like that was that was it that
was the one it was really hype it had me really into it and I've watched a
haikyo I've watched I've watched and read the manga of Prince of Tennis
because I've read the manga first before I watched the anime so I read the manga
I read Prince of Tennis I free haikyo I liked haikyo a lot I liked a lot of a
lot of the anime is any opinion on the JoJo series I watched the whole JoJo
series I've seen the whole thing all of it I love that I just people there's a
what's that sumo anime called haji haji haji something sumo I don't know sumo I
watch that too I really love the opening of that song a lot it's one of my
favorite openings he know he mode he no matter sumo yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the opening is so awesome I love it it's a really good opening I
didn't expect it and I think the opening is what really made me continue to watch
the anime have you seen our bleach I haven't seen the new bleach stuff that
came out because I don't like cliffhangers so I was waiting for a majority of
episodes to come out cuz I like to bench sit down with some ice cream some
popcorn turn off my lights good comfy cozy wrapping up like it and then bench
big old bench I haven't seen the new bleach yet but I stopped at the the old
old bleach I seen the whole season like can you get a big hug yeah you can get a
big hug a big hug there you go yeah hug for a job
binging is the best favorite bleach opening oh that's hard that's very hard
because I listened to like a bunch of openings and I think all of them are
really good I don't know that one stuck in my head so that one gets easily stuck
in my head so probably that one I think it's opening six if I remember correctly
yeah I think that's opening sex
NASA loans now I'm stuck in my head it gets stuck in my head really like fast
do you watch harem anime I do but I am not like a mega big fan of certain harem
anime because I'm not a fan of certain MC characters that are like like
extremely dumb they make me really mad
it makes me super mad with how dense they could be like how can you be so
dense how how how are you stop it are you dumb
who's right with you she wants you
I watched it is only certain harem anime that really catch my attention and I
guess it's I guess it's where the MC sometimes really don't want anything to
do with the other girls and they don't get beat up I like where the girls
aren't that cliche niche where they like beat up the MC all the time for like
small things like really small things like why are you beating him up why why I
thought his joke was really funny I thought it was funny I laughed
he didn't do nothing wrong
especially if you really like the character like if she the character
right really likes the MC and he happened to see something right and he
actually generally felt bad about it why hit him there's no need to hit him
it'll be different if he was like one of those characters to really really really
really really poorly what and they did that you know the extreme I would get it
I would get one in you know beat them up all right but so Cassie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we're them up deserved
guy probably not dense because I keep hitting him in the head
its probably true
I've seen Beyblade X. I don't have a big opinion on it actually. I've seen it so long ago
that I don't really have it. I can't really give an opinion on like extremely extremely
old anime or shows or cartoons because they're really old. That's like asking me what are
my opinions on Pokemon and I've watched the entire Pokemon series. I'm a huge Pokemon
fan. I've played almost a majority of all Pokemon games. I love Pokemon. Do I have an
opinion on the show itself? No. I don't. I don't. I can't give you that. I can't give
you that answer. I love Pokemon. That's all that matters. I even have a Digimon plushie
sitting up there. But Digimon plushie, Pikachu plushie, a bunch of plushies. I collect quite
a lot of them. Oh my god someone mentioned Negima. Oh my god I really loved Negima. I
don't know why. But I loved Negima. It gets a pass. A big pass for me. He was an intelligent
character. He was really smart. He may be a little bit dense but he was smart. I liked
him. I liked Negima. That was good anime. Singles for that Yokai anime. What was it called?
It's not really a harem. I wouldn't really call it a harem anime. What was it called?
It's like the Yokai anime where he turns into the guy with the really long hair. The white
hair that comes out really long in the back. Yeah. Yes! That's the one. That's the one.
Oh my god I can't even say that. I can't even say that. I'm gonna butcher it. I can't
for that stuff. Look I said I'm still learning Japanese. The big words like that's hard. It
is norari. I like that one. That's good. I sure people mentioned some more anime but
I probably missed it. I'm sorry if I missed it. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I've seen a few
other anime. We've been talking about anime for almost literally an hour. Oh no. No tarem.
We have the hardest role. Yes I've seen Shaman King. I can tell you my favorite cartoons
or anime from Four Kids TV. I watched Yu-Gi-Oh! Pokemon. Spider Writers. I watched Bakugan
and Battle Brawlers. I watched all of them. Everything. I literally went on when I first
got my big chunky PC. I was like binging all the shows that I could get my hands on. With
the Wicked Rise, The World Girl, Howling Hall, Spider Writers. Spider Writers V2. If you
truly want to be V2, it's cool. You can join our team. I know all the songs too.
Oh, I like my favorite song. I like the original Yu-Gi-Oh! But there's not a lot of singing. It's
just. But I think Five D's was my favorite. Yu-Gi-Oh! Five D's.
Feel the wind is blowing me around. Take a shot at me and run this side by side. It's
a blur as I go by. I can't hear you breathing. I can't see you coming. I can't feel the wind
is blowing me around. See the sunrise and fire in the sky. Greatness thrust itself into our lives.
Yeah.
I loved Yu-Gi-Oh! Five D's. It was good. And the show called Blue Dragon. Blue Dragon, yeah.
It looks like, I think the artist is literally the creator of Dragon Ball Z because they look the
same. They look exactly the same. I've watched Detective Conan. Yes, yes, yes. Isn't Detective
Conan still ongoing? I've watched like a few seasons but I don't think I've continued to watch it
because there was so much. It's like one piece and I'm like also watching one piece as well.
It's like the Conan is still kicking.
Blue Dragon game was kind of ass. It's true. I agree. But the series was pretty good. And then it
just kind of died. I don't know what happened to it. I don't know if it got cancelled or something.
It just was gone. The show Akira, I watched that too.
Goddess of Anime and Fertility.
Any genre I dislike? Probably Mecha. I'm sorry everyone. I'm sorry. There's only a few Mecha
that are in my heart early. But any other Mecha besides Neon Genesis, besides Full Metal Panic,
Code Geass. If it's not those animes, I don't like it.
I love Code Geass. I love Full Metal Panic and I love Neon Genesis. And was it, was the other one?
There was another Mecha anime that I like but I don't remember the name of.
Even Gallant. Yes, yes, yes. I like that too. No worries. No worries there. If it's not those,
if it's like those other Mecha anime, I'm not really a big fan.
Oh, I love Fuli Kuli. I love Fuli Kuli. Fuli Kuli is awesome. What? It's not even like a big Mecha anime.
I like Goren Lagin but I really hate one of the characters.
One of the female characters made me angry so she makes me not like the show.
Eruka 7? I like Eruka 7. Like I said, there's only a few Mecha anime that win my heart over.
Only a few. Majority of the new ones I don't really like.
Yes, I watched Sparx Family. I really like the first season so I haven't really, I started
on the next season but I haven't gone up to date so I like watched three episodes of the new season
and then I kind of stopped. Their approach on the new season kind of like got me a little bored
because they're like individually going at every character, giving each character their own episode.
They didn't really do that in the first season so it kind of throws me off a little bit because I don't
really like, usually it was a combination of everyone and then focused on Anya and now it's
everyone gets their own special episode and I kind of like don't care.
I don't know if that's just me not being able to process it very well but
have you seen To Your Internity? To Your Internity is the first anime to ever make me cry
in the first episode. The first anime to ever make me cry in the first episode.
I love Death Note, of course I do. Oh my god, I love Durarara. I love Durarara as well.
We're gonna sit here and talk about anime this entire time. There's so much stuff I wanted to talk about.
I'm having fun. This is fun. Talking about anime gives you like really relaxed,
really into it and it's like one of my biggest passions because when I'm really sad and feeling
down and you know, I want to watch anime. It makes me feel so much better.
So I like binged anime like throughout my whole life. Anime is great.
Free Wren. Free Wren is, I finished that whole, I think that anime was amazing.
There are a lot of hate on Free Wren. There's so much hate on that anime because it's like,
it seems boring to the eyes of a lot of people. It doesn't meet the target audience,
but I think it's so good. It tackles a whole another view on adventure as a whole.
All anime is always focused, fantasy focus is always on the focus of what happens before.
They defeat the demon lord, what happens before, everything they have to do and go through and
you build this like towards the character in the moment. But imagine being someone who lives
for a long time and being surrounded by people who don't and you spent an entire time living
up with these people throughout your whole life and then they're gone.
And now you have this, now it's like usually, anime would end on that and be like, oh that was the
story of how we defeated the demon lord and then we'll never see what happens afterwards. We get
to see the after, the memories and still gain a connection to old characters that you don't see
later on and I think that's really awesome. And then the animation is amazing given the fact
that it was drawn by hand. Everything was drawn by hand. It is amazing. They did so good for,
especially for a studio that was, you know, a lot of their stuff in the past was really bad.
They stepped it up. They stepped it up with this anime. Oh sorry, I got really into that one. I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry, I got really passionate with that one.
Oh yes, I watched Assassination Classroom. I think it's a really good anime as well.
I feel so bad for the the elf though, for Friren. Given the fact that she is, you know,
an elf and living for a long time, you don't really process the feelings of how humans process them.
So I understand that. I really do understand that of being so out of touch with their own emotion
sometimes and not understanding the concept of love and other feelings of, you know, things like
that because, you know, when you say I'll see you later for an elf, that could be like, I'll see you
later, like a hundred years later, like imagine someone liking you and you're like, and it's
whatever. And then they like, then they're gone and then you're like, well, damn, well, damn.
Now you know, you know, you cry, you cry. All you could do is cry and you feel for her like, oh,
it took her so long to realize this and understand.
Make me cry. I'm really emotional when it comes to watching anime. Anime does not fail to make
me cry. If it's like really an emotional part or piece, I will probably cry.
Pixel games? Yeah, I like pixel games, like, you know, like One Shot,
Stardew Valley, you know, games like that. I like those kind of games, but I didn't really know
how to like pinpoint it, like Terraria. I call those pixel games because I don't know what else to
call them though. I call those pixel games. I don't know what else to call them though.
Yeah, I like Cal World. I like open world games and building games. I like farming games. I like
simulating games. I like games where you just shut your brain off and play. I love it. I do, do, do.
Let me do a Monster Hunter stream. I want to, I'm a little nervous too, because it's not a game that I
play often, but I have played it a few times and I loved it, but I never found the time to play it
again. So I played it a few times, so it became one of my favorite games to play every now and then.
Um, do I like the game Dead by Daylight? I have played it once when it was free to play,
but I've never actually played it, but I have watched some gameplay because I did like the game
itself. It looks fun, but yeah. I really do like One Shot a lot because I think it's super cute.
I liked it so much so that I ended up getting a Nico, a Nico plushie. I have a Nico plushie,
and the light bulb is like magnet and it like attaches to his hands.
That's one of my favorite games. I really like that. So I can't wait to play it again. I'm so
excited to play it once more. Yeah, I mean, or for the first time ever. Yeah.
I actually added a few games that I haven't played. No, I haven't actually, I'm reading this list.
There's only one game I haven't played and that's Little Nightmares. I have the game and I've had
the game in my library for a really, really long time, for a really, really, really long time,
but I've never played it. So it's been a game that I've been wanting to play for a really long time.
This is there.
Yeah, I hear it's short, but I want to play the whole series, Little Nightmares.
One, two, and I don't think three is out yet. So that's why I want to play it.
All right, fine. Fine. I've been seeing this question a lot. All right. Listen to me. Listen
to me. Listen to me. Listen to me. Are you guys listening? Are you listening? Are you listening?
Can you hear me? Are you listening? Listen to me. Listen, listen, listen.
I like it, all right? I like it. I like it. I like League of Legends. All right? All right? All right?
I like League of Legends.
Look, look, look, look, look, look. I don't know why. Look, I don't know why.
I don't know why. I do not recommend playing this game. Don't play it. It's a dictation.
But I played it for so long. I played it for so long. For so, so very long. All right? I can't help it.
It's a good game for me. I don't listen. I don't, I don't really talk in the chat. I don't really
talk in the, in the game. I don't really, I just like to turn off my brain, play some good old norms,
go mid lane, and just farm, murder a person in a game.
And, and, and, you know, just chat, you know? It's like really, it's like,
it's like the, it's like a good chatting stream for me. I have ADHD and I like flashing colors,
okay? I like the flashing colors and the abilities. While I'm just literally staring at my screen,
all right? I've gotten so far in the game as in like, it's like, it's like a, it's like a
gotcha game, almost kind of like, similar. Yeah. I have so much stuff on it, on the account that I had
that I, I didn't want to stop playing. I collected so much stuff. I was like, I don't want to stop
playing. I got so much stuff, I could get more, more, I need more, more, please, more, please, more.
Please, please. I almost have every champion, more champions, more, more.
We can fix her.
We're rolled to your man. I usually made mid. I usually made mid lane, but sometimes I go support.
But I made mid. My favorite champion that I like to play is Zyra.
She's a babe, bro. That's a very hot babe.
Something about her seeds being inside of you, some chat.
Isn't that one of her lines?
Wait until my, wait as I plant my seeds inside of you.
That's one of her voice lines. I swear. I swear.
I swear.
Wait.
I could be a little bit thummy sometimes.
Hey, sometimes.
Only if you want me to be.
Look, all right. I know some of you have sent me a lot of things asking if I was
so boredom and stuff like that, but I'm, I'm, I'm just, I'm weird.
You'll get what I give you and you'll love it regardless. So does it really matter?
You'll probably get a little bit of both. So, you know.
All right.
That's the first one. The answer is I swear to you.
Chat volume warning.
Okay. We've been on this slide for a while. We could always talk about more anime
and another like Zazzledon stream or something. It's a little just chatting stream.
So let's move on. I want to just go over some more things and stuff with you guys.
We, we spent over an hour on that. Maybe we could talk more about it another time.
We have, we have more than enough time to talk about so many things, right?
So many, so many things.
But yes.
To say my name was anime talk true. All right. I'm about to keep thing up with time. So
it feels shorter. It really does. It feels like we just started.
I do want to say
that these cookies have been staring at me this entire time and they're taunting me.
And I want to eat them. I want to eat them so bad.
I want you to understand me. I want you to know that I do. I know a lot of people were like confused
about my, wait, was that, was it squishy, squishy, squishy, squishy? Are you a baker? Because I want to
grab your, bro, bro, bro.
Squishy why? Squishy why?
I thought it was like a genuine question.
I got trolled.
Dang it. Papa's over here scaring, trolling me.
I believe there is a public discord server that gives you notifications when we go live and
stuff. But we are not in it. You will not find us in it. But I do recommend joining it if you
want updates for when everyone goes live. Especially me. Because I know you want to be
up to date whenever I'm here. I want everyone to see me, hear my voice, talk to me.
Oh my god.
I'm gone.
Oh my tootie crap.
I didn't go anywhere. I don't know what you're talking about. I was here the whole time.
I was here the whole time.
Oh, we're fine. Everything's fine. Everything's okay.
You're probably going to experience so much scuff and all my streams, extreme extreme scuff.
We're fine. Everything's great.
All right. So yes, I am a baker. I bake stuff sometimes when I'm like feeling like in a really
mood to have sweets and I really want it. I make brownies, cupcakes, cakes.
I was learning how to make cheesecakes and all sorts of stuff. Grand crackers, cookies.
So many other stuff.
So, however, these are things that I wanted to do on stream, like a handcam stream and stuff like
that. So I want to do these things. I want to cook for you guys and show you my cakes and stuff,
but I am very limited in being able to do that with my living situation.
Yeah, I live with a pretty big family. So doing that won't be possible right away.
So when I'm able to move out, which I hope is soon, but I would have to save up quite a bit
before I could do that. I will be free to do a lot more things for streams and stuff like that.
That's so sudden.
I want to make threads and fake stuff.
For now, I could just like show you like pictures and stuff on stream or on Twitter,
the Twitter, Twitter, or X, I mean, sorry, X, X, Xter, X sweeter. What do you call it?
Is it okay to say that here? Can I say that here?
I want to show you pictures and stuff, and I'll do that and stuff right now.
I still call it Twitter.
I want, I think, Stronius spoke about this, about how there were some people wanting to make
cover songs. I think I was one of the girls that really, really, really, really, really,
super one to make of our song. I want to sing for you guys. I want to sing for you guys.
I sing songs and stuff for you. I'm very subconscious of my voice when I speak normally. I'm really
surprised you guys like my voice. I was really surprised when Stroni liked my voice. I was
all very surprised. This is a very honest opinion of mine. A lot of people think my voice is fake
or my voice is like I'm doing too much. There are people who would always tell me that I sound
like a child or a kid. Or I sound like a pupas and child and stuff like that. People tell me that
all the time. But I've been very subconscious of my voice for a long time.
To me, I think my voice is horrible. But a lot of you really like my voice. So I'm happy. You do.
I'm happy. I'm glad you like it. But I do have a list. So I pronounce a lot of words really
badly. I have a really bad list. List. List. I swear the person who created that word is evil.
They created that word knowing that people with one can't say it. They're evil. That's all I'll say.
They're evil. So that's why I speak the way I speak. Because I have a list.
So I'm sorry. I'm really sorry if my grammar is wack.
Or we're getting off track.
I am
really new to the ASMR scene.
I hope you don't mind. I'm a little new to ASMR scene.
So I hope you don't mind.
Drunk. A lot of people say that. That I sound like that. That I'm drunk. Do I?
Really? Do I sound like I'm drunk? But you don't really want to know what it really sounds like
when I get drunk. I don't know how a drunk person really sounds. But this is how I sound.
I don't know. It's very common. A lot of people say it. My family says the same thing to me.
That I always sound like I'm drunk. So I don't know. I think it's just my speech. It's very slurrish.
It's very slurrish. And the combination of the list makes it a lot more worse.
So yeah. I do have plans to do a drunk stream. But I want to also go over some things that
I kind of have to deal with that. With the drinking part thing. So
I do want to let everyone know that I am a little sickly.
I've been sick since I was like really young. I've had a lot of issues going on with like
my stomach. Intestinal issues. A lot of issues there. They found like a
kind of like a mass. But not like a
the the C word. Serous. The C word. Serous mass. It was found in my nose. My nasal cavity.
And it infected a lot of tissue. And I had to get that surgically removed.
So I have a lot of nasal issues. So that could also be why I sound kind of stuffy if I do to you.
But my nasal patches is pretty cleared up now after the surgery. So I'm good now.
So every now and then you'll probably I'll have to probably like spray my nose.
Just in case I get really stuffy. And then I start sounding like this the entire time.
Like I'm Squidward. And we don't want that.
So yeah.
So we don't want that.
I'm going miles per second. I click something I shouldn't have. All right, all right, we're fine.
And I'm not really green guys. I'm like I'm like a teal. I'm blue. All right. I look green.
But I'm blue. Don't let the colors fool you. The color spectrum is evil. All right. It's evil.
I see green. Yeah, I'm blue. All right.
I'm blue. And these are neck pillows. They are ears. They are my little gold ears. Okay. They're ears.
Please, please. Thank you.
That is all. Welcome back. Thank you for participating in my talk. Thank you.
Thank you.
But yes, I got a lot of physical issues with my shoulder.
My shoulder didn't develop properly. My shoulder didn't develop properly. And it took them like
many years for them to figure this out. So they finally took x-ray after telling me that I was
fine saying it was stress, stress, stress, stress, stress, stress. It's fine. It's fine. You're fine.
You're fine. And then they finally took x-ray. I got a better doctor like this is my 10th 12th
doctor that I went through. And they finally took x-ray. They seen that my shoulder is
didn't develop fully. So it causes pain in my right hand and in my elbow. And it travels
through my whole arm. So I have extreme pain. So I'm on like a bunch of pain medication.
So it makes me kind of loopy a little bit. So I'm just another reason why I probably sound like I'm
drunk. I also have my spine at my neck is isn't curved like a sea like it's supposed to. It's
actually straight. So I have permanent headaches that don't really go away. And I've had them
for a long time for years.
So I got a, I have pink colors for that too.
So yeah.
This is where I'm going to be the second care of you.
No.
I'm fine. Don't worry. I'm fine. I just want to be treated like everyone else.
A lot of people I usually tell always end up feeling really bad for me. Don't feel bad for me.
I just want to live my life. I want to live a life. It was really hard enough for me to
find work like outside of everything. People wouldn't hire me. And when they did hire me,
I was limited to doing stuff and they didn't like that. And I had to visit, I have to visit
a doctor every week. I have doctor's appointments every week. So they were upset that I had to
take time off every week. They didn't like that. They wanted me, they wanted all my time. So they
would always end up, you know, firing me. Whenever I got randomly sick on the job, they would get
upset. Ambulance had to come pick me up one time because I got really, really badly sick.
So I had stomach problems. So my stomach is very sensitive. If I eat certain food,
I could get food poisoning pretty easy. It could be really bad.
So I have a lot of issues. I don't mind talking about them. I really don't. I think I
saw that in there. I can show you. I don't mind talking about them. I don't. However,
I would appreciate if people wouldn't ask too much questions on it though. I appreciate it.
Please, please thank you. I just want to let you know now so that everyone knows and that if
anyone else asks, it's out there. The information is out there.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There's some other issues I have. But a lot of it just deals with my, I was kind of
malnourished for a while. Yes, I'm a huge eater. I eat a lot and I used to, I have a really fast
metabolism. So I would eat like nonstop. This was like a few years ago. I used to eat like
three pizza pies, three whole pizza pies by myself. My metabolism is that fast. It was
that fast. I think it's slowly slowing down. Maybe, I don't know, I don't think so.
I eat a lot. So I'm a big foodie. I like food a lot.
But because of this, because I eat a ton or not enough when I need to, because I can go like
days without eating because I will forget. I feel like I like have this thing where I forget to eat.
And I wouldn't eat for days and stuff like that. So and then I'll have a random binge day and I'd
eat like a ton. So technically today, today I forgot to eat. Today, today I forgot to eat.
I'll tell the ones I didn't eat today.
I also forgot to eat yesterday.
But my family made me something to eat yesterday after they built. Don't worry.
Don't worry. Don't worry. I ate a little bit yesterday. It wasn't a lot, but I still ate a
little bit yesterday. Like a plate. I ate like one plate of something.
Don't tell everyone. No. Don't tell everyone. No. Don't tell.
Eat silly. Oh, eat. Eat. Don't tell Stroney. Don't tell Stroney.
But that's really just scold me. I'm getting in trouble. I'm getting in trouble.
Let me eat the cookies. I have cookies. I have cookies. I'll eat this. I'll eat this.
What the? Isn't this supposed to be like a a flap? Oh, you peel it like this.
Cool. Okay. That's my acacia slice. I sat on them so I broke them. I accidentally sat on them.
I forgot I put them in my in my in my chair.
Free ASMR.
It should have been me. It's not fair.
It should have been me.
Nani water. Hang on. It should have been me. Not him.
Well, was that a good impersonation?
All right. I ate a cookie. There you go.
I ate a cookie and got any milk with those cookies? I do.
Yeah, I got milk. Got milk. Yeah.
I like to drink tea with these, though, these cookies. They're
what do you call it? They're shortbread cookies called
Lorna Dome? Lorna Dome? Lorna Dome? Lorna Dome or Lorna Dome? I don't know. One of the two.
Yeah, Lorna Dome or Lorna Dome cookie. They're good. They're my favorite. I like those a lot. Good cookies.
They're like, yeah, they're like, it's called shortbread, shortbread cookies.
Sort of like a, I don't know if it's a biscuit. Maybe a biscuit?
That's a biscuit.
It's pronounced Dome. Lorna Dome. Lorna Dome. Yeah, Lorna Dome.
Yeah, it tastes really good with tea. I like it with tea the most.
If you guys have them, you should try it. I think you should.
They're yummy. I have a really big sweet tooth and a salty tooth. I don't know if you call it a salty tooth.
I really like salt, salty foods, like really, really salty foods. I have a slim gym addiction.
Oh my god, I have HD bad. Like, we were talking about one thing and then we go to another and then to another and then to another and then to another, we never stay on topic.
I
Need tea recommendations
I know I'm gonna say this tea wrong and
A lot of people always correct me
But say it wrong on is it
Chum, chum, chum
Chum, oh
Chum, oh come come on. Chum, oh
Chum
Chum, oh tea
Chum, oh, lech, chum, chum, ah, chum, ah, chum, oh
My oh, chum, oh my oh
Oh
Come on meal come on meal come on meal come on here come on here. Yeah
Come on, yeah
Yeah, I'm a meal T. Yeah, yeah, that one.
I did it.
I do like Camomile tea.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Earl Grey.
I like Earl Grey.
I really like tea.
Different types of tea.
Drink many types.
I like milk tea as well.
Milk tea is good.
You guys want to know a secret?
Come here, tell your secret, tell your secret.
I'm lactose intolerant.
I'm fat and I'm also sugar intolerant.
I can't have gluten, I can't have gluten.
But that doesn't stop me, all right?
I love me some cheese.
I love me some milk, some good old ice cream.
I should be eating these cookies right now, but here we are.
Oh, yeah.
So good.
It's so good.
How could you not?
It's like a curse.
All my favorite foods consist of milk and sugar.
I just have to be careful.
And so I know someone asked me about what kind of milk I like.
And I've been drinking almond milk, but I think I might have a slight peanut allergy,
but I'm not sure.
So I'm going to go take a test to go find out soon.
Almond milk is so good though.
I did the sweetened one though, and I didn't realize that there was a sweetened version,
and I grabbed that without looking, brought that home, drunk that, and then died the next day.
It was bad.
It was my stomach.
It was so bad.
What happened?
What's going on?
Why does it hurt so bad?
Help, help me.
I've never had rice milk before, or oat milk before, and I want to try it.
I want to try it.
So maybe I'll try it out on another Zazzledon stream, or just chatting the stream like now,
until you guess how I feel about it.
I hope you guys have like brands.
I need brands.
I need the fine ones.
Find the best ones.
I can drink and stuff.
Milk sampling stream.
Yeah!
All kinds of milk.
I think rice milk.
Don't they use rice milk or just rice to make rice wine or something like that?
Or am I like having a moment right now?
Cause I don't know.
Yeah, sake.
Is it just rice?
I thought they put rice milk in it as well.
Or is that just different brands of sake that do different things?
Or am I just...
I've only had sake once.
One time.
And on the menu, it was called rice wine.
So...
That was the first time I had sake.
And I don't remember...
Don't remember...
What it tasted like.
Because before that, I was drinking a lot of soju.
I was kind of drunk that day.
I was drinking a lot of soju.
I was a really, really big drunk that day.
And then we visited like Korean barbecue.
Korean barbecue.
It's not a vibe.
It's not that scary.
But she's just hot.
She gets really strict when she needs to.
I might do later on down the line.
I could see it happening.
So, I wanted to say that...
To go over all the sick stuff that I've mentioned so far.
If you can remember all the things I just listed.
Because there was all over the place, I'm sorry.
In order to keep up with my health, I have to do a bit of exercise.
I'm gonna keep myself nice and fat.
Nice and fat.
I forgot.
Which is what gave me the idea.
To do ASMR workout streams.
Where I whisper and tell you guys where to go.
And we exercise together.
So, we could do my workouts together.
So, I have to do things like yoga.
And keep my arm strength up.
To handle my shoulder issue.
And my neck issue.
Because if the rest of my body can't hold up my own big old head.
I had to make it all strong.
I had to make it all strong to help with that pain.
My doctors are yelling at me.
You need to get stronger.
Stronger. Worked out.
Unfit.
So, I had to do that.
Pits just arrived.
I'm so jealous.
So, yeah.
So, with all the food I'm eating and stuff.
Can go to...
The rest of my body.
And I cannot...
You know.
Be a big, big, big strong.
So, those streams will probably be...
I don't...
I think those will be streams here on YouTube.
If I'm able to.
Because I'm not sure if I...
Those would be okay to do.
Maybe we could like test the waters.
But I'd have to see how Stroni feels about that.
And then...
Um...
I know a lot of people really want me to do...
Like the...
The hypnosis stuff.
And the...
Extreme dummy stuff.
Or be extreme dumb.
I think I covered some of that.
But I don't think I'm going to be taking over any of the girls.
Other girls' roles.
That's their thing.
That's what they do.
And...
I would have to discuss...
Maybe some...
Things...
With my gen mates to see how they feel about it.
Maybe collabs or something.
A little collab here and there.
You know?
I like to be vague.
I don't like telling you guys anything.
I know everyone else is really sharing with you.
On what everyone's doing.
But I like to surprise people.
I really like to stay on the download.
And I go...
I did a thing.
Do you see it?
Are you looking at it?
Do you like it?
I don't like sharing.
I like the mystery.
It's fun.
And I love seeing all your reactions.
When it does come out.
Where everyone freaks out.
Talking about how I'm hiding my true powers.
I've seen the morows.
I got quite a few morows about the shock.
I bide my time and wait.
To surprise you.
Mystery milk.
So there are things in the work.
And there are things that are being planned out.
And it caters quite a lot.
To a lot of the things that were asked for.
Some of the...
A lot of the things that were asked for.
So you won't have to worry about a thing.
It's probably gonna be there.
Most likely.
But will I say it is?
So if anyone wants to know about any of the saucier stuff.
ASMRs and stuff that's most likely gonna be on the Patreon.
You'll find it.
In the description.
If anyone else wants to send me more morows.
That's also in the description.
Is that what you call?
Did I do that right?
I do like teasing.
It's fun.
Yes!
Mertz 2.
Also in the description.
No, just sleep under your chair.
My ears.
You wanna see one of my ears?
Please, thank you.
Are they nice and fluffy?
Are they really soft?
You wanna touch them?
Wanna wrap them around you like a blanket?
I'm gonna get on to the merch very soon.
I was going to save that for last.
Okay, we'll talk about that soon.
Thank you for the reminder.
I have a list of things to talk to you guys about.
We're gonna talk about this.
And then this.
And then we just spend hours talking about anime.
I don't think I...
I'm not really...
I'm really bad at using the moral.
The marshmallow.
The moral.
I'm really bad at using it.
So I don't know how to post things.
I'm so sorry.
It's like...
It's my first time using this thing.
So I'm slowly figuring things out.
So...
What's that?
The moral is the marshmallow.
Where you can ask me questions there.
And usually I will answer your questions there.
Or send it to you via there.
So you can send me stuff in there.
And you know.
I'm like old.
Says you.
Gotta speaking.
Hello.
Been around for eons.
You know?
Kinda...
Kinda been around for a long time.
You know?
Been around for a long, really long time.
Yeah.
Uh...
Got us here.
Yee-haw.
Hell yeah, brother.
That's right.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Understand.
That's good.
Yeah, yeah.
Yee-haw.
Guess what?
Those are good.
Sorry.
You could just...
You could like...
There's like a permanent translate.
Like...
I think...
There's a permanent...
You could add...
You could put a permanent Google translate.
At the top.
It pops up for me.
You could like put a permanent...
Like a little...
Little thingy.
And it translates it for you.
Just hit random buttons until it works.
That's about it, kind of you.
We're riding away to the sunset with this one.
I don't know if I should say...
Yeah, I don't know if I should say...
I know a lot of people are wondering what my accent is.
I heard some cries about my accent and not being able to figure it out.
But I'm not Aussie though.
Keep the accent a mystery?
Sure, I can do that.
But what I can tell you is this.
I am not Dutch.
No, I'm learning Dutch.
I've traveled to the Netherlands before, I think last year.
And it was fun.
So, I'm learning Dutch.
Dutch, Dutch, Dutch, Dutch, Dutch.
Alright, so I'm going to tell you.
I don't speak various languages.
But I was raised around various communities.
And...
What do you call it?
So what do you want it?
Yes, I was raised around a lot of ethnic groups.
She's just turning to her roots.
Thank you.
Oh, my bleeding heart.
That's so cute.
I like that so much.
But when I was younger, I was raised around a lot of people who spoke Spanish.
A lot of people who spoke Spanish.
I don't speak the language.
A lot of them were Mexican and Puerto Rican.
So I was raised around a lot of people who spoke Spanish for a long time.
So I don't speak Spanish, but because they spoke to me in Spanish a lot and never in English,
I had to learn to understand Spanish.
I'm not good at it now, but I was really good at it before where they would talk to me, have a conversation in Spanish,
and I would just do or respond in English.
So I cannot read Spanish.
I can't read it. I can't do that. I'm sorry.
And then as I got older, I was raised around a lot of people who spoke Japanese and Korean and Mandarin.
I met a lot of people who came overseas to visit where I live, and they spoke Japanese.
So I learned a lot from them when I was younger.
I just so happened to be interested in anime.
So a lot of people used to be like, oh, you want to be trying to do that.
You want to be, want to be, want to be.
It's whatever. I don't care.
But I was friends with a lot of people who were Asian, so I just picked up a lot of their manualisms.
I picked up a lot of their manualisms, and I started learning Korean and Japanese back then.
No, not Cantonese, but Tengalong.
And Tengalong.
I knew some people who spoke Tengalong, which I think is the Philippines.
Filipino. I was friends with a lot of Filipinos.
And then as I got older, as I got older, I was friends with a lot of people who spoke Russian.
I didn't travel. I didn't go anywhere. I just happened to meet these people.
I was just surrounded by these people.
You know how you meet one person, and then they introduce you to their group of friends,
and their whole group of friends speak that one language, but you, you're the only one?
I was always the one person in the group that spoke only English.
That was me. I was that person.
I was always the one person in every group, so just the one person that didn't speak the language.
I was that one person.
So, yeah.
So I met a bunch of people who spoke Russian, and then they started teaching me Russian, and they started teaching me.
And they started, like, talking about it and doing that and doing this, and I was like, oh, yeah, it's cool, it's cool.
And then there was some people in the group who were Swedish and Poland.
And so they started teaching me some of the things that they say, some of the words they say, and Swedish and Poland, and I was like, oh, cool, cool, cool.
I started learning that for, like, a year.
But of course, nothing sticks because I'm dumb.
Nothing ever sticks. I'm interested in it for a little while, and then I just kind of, like, since I have no one to talk to in that language, it's gone.
It's gone.
And then after that, after that, I started learning Dutch, yeah.
And then I actually left for the first time ever to go to the Netherlands.
That was my first time ever leaving my country.
That was my first time. I've never left it before, so I was excited.
It was very scary, but it was really fun.
I was very happy, and I had a lot of fun. I ate a lot of food, and it was really fun.
Would I go again? Yes.
I want to travel more. It's like my biggest dream, because with my health, I was scared that I wasn't going to be able to do that.
To travel and stuff, because my health is, like, really bad.
So I was very happy to travel for the first time ever.
And when I got my passport, I was so excited. I cried.
I got emotional.
I was crying.
It was good. It was good. It was fun. I had a fun time.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my God. I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
We're fine. We're fine.
I'm a big strong girl.
I don't cry.
Crying. I don't do that.
We don't cry here.
We're fine.
More.
Why?
But yeah.
But the last thing on this thread I wanted to mention was fan art.
I'm okay with any fan art, as long as it's not, you know, the, you know, that word down there.
As long as it's not done, we're fine.
Please and thank you.
Draw what you want. Draw what you will.
Anything goes. I don't care on paper, little doodles.
I don't care. Art is art. There's not just anything as bad art.
I don't care what it looks like.
Let me share it with the world.
I really like art. I'm an artist myself.
I draw too, but I'm a lazy artist.
So you only get flat colors and messy sketches from me.
I do draw really detailed stuff sometimes, but I have really bad.
I have a zone that I get into and I can draw for hours.
I remember drawing for like 24 hours.
I didn't eat. I didn't sleep.
I didn't use the bathroom.
I don't know what happened. It was like a zone. I was in a zone.
And I went into extreme details on the art that I drew and I was like going in and I'm like, yeah.
And if I stop, I can never get that back and draw what was ever on my mind.
And then I get like stuck and I can't finish the piece and it goes undone forever.
So I get in a zone and I can't really leave it.
So that's why I only doodle like sketches and I try to leave it at that.
I do a doodle and I throw a little color in there and I leave it.
Or it's just the doodle when I go like I did. I posted this.
So yeah.
Yeah, I'm trying to keep you guys here for as long as possible.
I'll give you company until you see your little sharp friend.
I was going to keep this so short, but I don't know. I don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened. We just started rounding about everything.
This is supposed to be like a super short stream.
I'm supposed to be so short.
But I'm rambling. Oh gosh. Am I the apper?
Am I the apper?
Time does fly when you're having fun. It's true. I agree.
Okay.
Speaking Japanese.
Am I the endurance streamer from the company? Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I did it.
Sorry.
The voice is pretty enough. I'm going to say thank you.
I really don't understand. You guys like my voice.
Even Amy brought it up earlier and she was talking about it.
She was conscious of her voice. I think her voice is so cute.
I wish I could have a voice like hers.
It's just soft.
I think it's so cute.
It's so cute.
And same goes for Icy's voice. Icy's voice is so cute.
The small bien. The super small bien.
I'm going to smush both of them.
Smush them to their pop.
Everyone's voice is so good.
She's beginning to feel like a yep god.
A minimum reference.
I never really got to talk about my music taste.
It's a...
Everyone has a taste. A specific genre of music.
But I don't actually listen to extreme, huge range of music.
When I was younger, I used to be in a choir.
An advanced choir. So I sung songs a lot.
Choir like opera.
It's late.
It's a little bit you get.
You used to sing opera?
I don't want it to be too loud for the microphone.
I'm scared I'm going to blow your ears off.
When I sing like that, it gets really loud.
I used to listen to all sorts of music.
Classical rap.
K-pop. Japanese songs.
Japanese rock. Japanese pop.
Regular pop.
So many things. I listen to Mandarin songs.
Rock.
Metal. I really like metal.
Mose. They're fun too.
I listen to quite a bit.
I would call it a bit of everything.
We never do karaoke streams.
I want to. I do.
I do. I do. I do.
But since it's like...
Since I usually end up singing randomly on stream.
Just randomly out of the blue.
I get a little nervous.
When it comes to prepping for a karaoke stream. What songs are loud?
What can I pick? What can I sing?
You know how I get in trouble?
I'm nervous. I don't want to get in trouble.
So I don't know what songs to pick. I don't know what is appropriate.
You know, the YouTubes.
Don't come for me.
Bunk me upside the head and go dumb goat.
I'm so sorry.
I have a big range of music. I listen to a lot of anime.
Openings and songs. Opening and endings. I don't really skip them.
Because I like music. Music is like...
It speaks to me. It's my heart.
I get emotional when it comes to anime and music.
It's my heart. It's what I was raised for. For a long time.
So if lyrics suddenly start... If I start finally paying attention.
Usually you listen to a song and you never really...
You say you don't like the song. But then like a year later or two.
You listen to the lyrics and now you're like
What? Wow. This really hits me this time.
I like this. And now all of a sudden the song is your favorite.
After hitting on it for like a couple of years.
I kind of go through that quite often.
I'm crying in my room.
You feel the song but never learn it. This is true.
This is very true. I either feel the song, never learn it.
Or hate the song. Don't bother to learn it.
End up liking it.
Or just... Or like a song
So much that it's the... That like...
You have to play this song every day. Every day you go outside.
Play that song. Or repeat. Not stop.
I have songs like that. Where I like
listen to the song over and over and over again.
It might be a little acoustic there.
And that record.
Um...
Uh oh.
Oh here we go. Okay chat like
froze for me for a second.
I couldn't even read chat.
The heck?
Sorry about that.
I'll just stop moving.
There we go.
Uh oh. Uh oh. I used to love Scooby-Doo.
This was good stuff. Scooby-Doo was great.
Now chat's back. You're back. Don't worry. It's fixed.
It's fixed. You're live. You're live. You're live.
You're back. You're back.
Do I like plays? Does that mean I like plays as well? Sometimes.
I am... I can't really... I have a hard time
focusing. So if the music isn't really catchy. Or like
pulls me in.
I'll... I'll... I'll probably fall asleep.
If I'm honest. I'll probably fall asleep.
I'll probably fall asleep.
If it's like long winded speech plays
like where they're just talking. I'll probably fall asleep. I usually wake up
but I used to go to plays a lot and I would wake up when they start singing.
It would always be when they're singing where I will wake up.
When the moment they start like, she did this. What?
Oh my god. And then I'm just like...
But if it's all music? Probably. I'll probably pay attention to it.
I've seen Hamilton before I believe.
So yeah.
If it's all music I'll probably... I'll probably
have a good watch. A good listen.
Because I can clap along like, yay!
Yay!
And if it's a song I know, I'll sing along.
Okay.
I don't know what that was.
Are there more slides?
Yeah. I was going to go over the goals again
but we already did that and we ignored that.
Oh yeah! Oh my god!
Oh my god I can believe we forgot!
I...
I'm so sorry. I'm just going so fast
and I... I... I...
I'm so sorry. I'm so distracted.
Mama forgot. Yeah, she forgot.
I had some ideas
for some tags so I had some. And I wanted to see
if you guys could come up with some as we went. So if any of you had
like...
some ideas for live and clips and memes
we could add them.
Whoa!
Let me try and not like open this right now.
And you got to...
Do live. Do la la...
Do live. Do live.
Asu live. Oh you remember
asu memes. Asu live. Asu clips.
And there was also asu laughs.
Oh no. Do lay laughs. Do lay laughs.
Sounds very exotic.
Do lay laughs.
Was it trying to trick my eyebrows?
Eyebrows moving too fast.
Ha ha ha.
Asu ha ha ha.
You guys like do live a lot, I see.
Ha ha ha.
Do ha s memes.
Biazura, Biazura, Biazura.
Ha ha ha.
Wait, hang on.
See ya.
Um, let's see if they grow out of this.
Um.
Okay.
My brain is slow, make this up.
Oh here we go. Let's grow up down.
Uh
Here we go. That's right. I'm here.
Oh.
Sorry, was I praying? Oh, I'm sorry.
Ha ha ha.
And
So there's asu live. Do you guys like
asu live or asu live?
How do you do a poll? I want to do a poll. How do you do a poll?
For the live. Which live hashtag you guys want?
Asu live or do a live? Are you doing a poll? I'm not useless. How do you do a poll?
I need a poll. How do you make
poll? I need poll.
How do you make poll?
How do you make poll? I got you. Don't worry.
I'm smart. I got this. I'm intelligent.
I'm intelligent.
I found it. I'm smart.
Which live
tag. Watch the mark.
Asu live
or do a live
like that. Am I smart or what?
Hell yeah. That's right. I'm intelligent.
I'm so smart.
Ha ha ha.
I'm intelligent. I'm smart.
That's right.
I'm smart. I'm actually smart.
And then it goes out like that.
Yay. I did it.
I mean, I knew this from the start. I knew how to do this.
I was just pulling your leg.
That's right.
That's right. I'm smart. I'm intelligent.
Ha ha ha.
when does the pole end? does it end by itself?
when does the pole end? wait, end it?
oh, I have to end it!
oh, okay, okay, I think everyone's voted so far, right?
there's more votes, so many more votes coming in
but I think it's pretty clear which one won though
and we end the pole, and the one that won
asal lives! asal life won!
alright, so we're gonna add that in here
stop it, please, come on, work for me
won't do me like that
alright, here we go, yeah, that's right
that's what I'm talking about
asal lives!
is it being used of fudge?
we gotta come up with something else then
let me check
no, we're gonna steal someone else's house tag
asal life
yeah, that belongs to someone
a couple of people actually
there's a few people who use the same one
not just one person, but it looks like they took it over
yeah, that's fine
alright, so I guess we have to use doolive
the doolive it is
we'll check it right now
a paxry boys
I went to go look it up real fast, and all I saw was paxry boys
that's funny
is that like an event?
like some sort of event?
oh my, I mean, I'm sure this event has other tags
they don't need this tag
oh yeah, this is really old, it was very long ago
it doesn't look
but like it's been used recently
so, I think we're free
free to use doolive
alright, doolive it is
next we'll do the next one
we have the clips, which is the daily doolay
I have daily doolay
and what else?
what was it?
or your other ideas for our clips?
milky moments, no, I don't think I can use that
there are other creators with that name
so I don't want to
take that
azuclips
sounds nice, I like that
I don't think I should use anything with goat in it
because there's like a bunch of other, you know, goats like myself
so, very sure
I want it to be like
kind of obvious it's mine
that's our goat
doolay clips
I'll add a third option
and I think that's the last one and you guys will have to pick from that, okay?
alright, starting pull now
which ones do you like?
which ones do you want?
my nose is itchy
scratch, scratch, scratch
I'll wait a little bit
little bit, little bit
scratch, scratch, scratch
and I think that
50, 50
it's like at a hard 50
let's count down from 3
3, 2, 1
and 0, we end the pull
what, 1?
it was no 50, I was wrong, I was off
it only showed me 1
doolay, daily doolay
it's daily doolay now
for the clips
daily doolay
ba, ba, ba
it's as good, it's as good
I'm blue, we're one for that
blue
let me see
I'm a nice little teal
nice teal, I'm a little teal teal goat
teal teal goat
blue green, blue green like the sea, like the ocean
the grand blue ocean
yes, I'm a teal teal teal goat
and hang on, let me um
write that down before I forget
we're gonna put that in here
it's daily doolay, I already had it
and then we have aso meme
doolay laughs
and if you wanna put in one
what other idea we could put in for a third option
let me pull this up
imagine if we made a hashtag
called
called for memes
and then it's called
biazura
laughs
wouldn't that be funny
is that taken?
that just came into my head
laughs
and there's just a bunch of
this is a bunch of
Skyrim and oblivion
memes in this tag
an elder scroll
and some more elder scroll
awesome, just elder scroll
good
we're gonna just end up taking over
this entire thread
biazura, that's it
there's nothing else in it though
it's empty, it's empty for me
it's empty, it's free
it's free
someone said
yeah, procorn, what's that?
the authoring fans
it's free real estate
right
psht
yeah, procorn is gold
wow, that's true, yep, procorn
biazura
alright, so I'm gonna
I'm gonna add a pool
sorry, pool
I'm gonna add
What's the mark?
There is also meme as a lap
Or is it do lay laps?
Labs then by a zero and then
Is that what you guys wanted yapper corn?
Is that what you wanted? No, I'm not alright. Is that just something you guys want to call me?
That's like an overall thing
Wow
Yes, and yes, I'll just add it just to add it, but I know which one's probably gonna win
Hey, I'll start it get the voting
There's a war, there's a war, there's a war, what about?
Oh no
They're winning by a landslide, oh my
And yes, they mean yapper corn as in not as in I'm a yapper, but yep
Wait
Wait, wait a minute
Wait, that's not just me and I'm a yapper
Wait a minute wait wait a minute wait a minute. I forgot I forgot
How dare
I
Didn't get it they said it was like capricorn and goat so I was like oh
Yeah, cool capricorn goat. Yeah yapper corn and it's my brain didn't think about it at all
Oh
Wow
Yapper corn should be live tag
I'll be I'll do you that I'll do you that and we'll make yapper corn the meme tag
Has nothing to do with the goat though, why me and I guess
Well, I yapper am I really like a pig yapper
By Azura so good
By Azura so good. Oh, I liked it too
How about this we make a new vote I have four
I don't know I don't know I don't know
By Azura does fit me
All right, how about I give you guys one more chance one more chance all right one more chance for the vote
All right one more we're only gonna put in
by Azura and
I
By Azura and
Yapper corn, right? Oh
What I press oh
But the African's gonna win again
I
Yeah, for corn for clips by Azura for for me that's a good idea
What do we have for clips again?
Daily delay well daily delay for clips
Daily delay
Okay, so
Hey, so
so
see
By Azura we can leave yapper
We can leave by Azura as the meme since I see everyone seems to agree with this
Everyone's like that more we're gonna do yapper corn versus
Daily delay
Okay, how's that?
Everyone's happy with that we're gonna vote on this one
He didn't know it is no yes heck yes
Yes
The people have chosen
And your goddess wills what she wants
And I think there should be a second poll
It's either it's either you guys pick it for like we don't have a lot
Do you want yapper corn for the live or do you guys want it for the
For the
For the live
Live
Live works live
Okay
live
Yeah, I see no no's
That's good. I like fairness. I like everyone being happy. That's good. Yeah
live
Yeah for live
You're also cute
How precious
You still like to live
I
Okay, okay for the live. All right
I'm gonna make it yapper corn for the live. How's that? Yapper corn for the live
Yapper corn for life
I
Daily to live stays and the means is by Azura
Everyone happy with that
Everyone happy with that. Yes
Yeah
That's our final decision on tags
Yay, yay, we did it
I
Just wanted to ask are you guys okay with being called bleeding hearts bleeding hearts? Are you guys okay with this?
I gotta make sure okay, you guys can't go nameless. Are you guys okay with bleeding hearts?
It's great
Bah
It's perfect bleeding heart is fun
He the oh she marks day oh she marks aren't getting changed
But I want to make sure you guys like the fun man and
I know you guys like your um
You're elder scroll
Scrolls, but I don't think we should call ourselves that. I hear it call yourself
It's cute. I love it, but we can keep it for like a inside joke. How's that?
Hmm, how's that?
And I can address you as adoring fans every now and then. All right, how's that keep that between us?
Okay
Yes
Good. I'm happy. I'm happy you're great, and
And that's it for that
And I think that's it I
Think we went over
Pretty much everything and then I just had these I wanted to just go over some of these and then that was it
We're good
We did it we made it through the slides
We did it
Yay
I
Picked out some morals, but I I'm praying
Properly filtered something
Let's go through this
We do that you're smart you're so smart you're so smart
Oh, that's not this one's not too bad
This is fine
I swear that's already in here it is
Yeah
Wow
So congratulations on your day feels as well
My question is in your opinion after working with VLOR for some time now
How would you describe their management?
They asked me if I could not ignore it. I say management is awesome
They work really hard to get everyone's stuff done and they
Get it done very quickly, and I think it's that's pretty cool, and they're very
How do you say?
understanding
very understanding and I
Appreciate that. I feel very welcomed and wanted and I really love it here already
And I hope it will continue to be the best
experience it can be
So far so please I really love this
Company so much already
I mean son has been very helpful the manager son has been very very very helpful and very good at what they do
All my mistakes were on me if I'm really honest I did make a
Trying to like fix stuff at PC issues. I had so many issues going on
The person who helped me out with all of that was means and manager
Manager help me out so much with everything so
I'm not a very tech savvy
so I
Appreciate that that hope that I got it was very necessary
So yeah, that's all I feel
The next question
Hello, that's debut
My question is have you met your gen maids in your life or have you only the chance to meet them online?
Also, what is your first impression on them? I've given my impression on them
very shortly during the deal and I
Really love them so much
They make me feel very
At home
I
Do get kind of nervous around them, and I've heard that I'm quite
Intimidating so I hope that we can warm up even more as time goes and we've done played games together already
Thank you saying I was really good at the game, but I just I don't know I I I I was just
Normally playing said games and enjoying it
So
I'm just very observant and I like to like pick out things I see it
I
Hopefully we'll warm up a little more and no I have not met them in real life yet, but maybe one day we will
And I hope that
That comes to the past and I really do want to meet my gen maids
I think it'd be really fun like going to conventions or cons together our events and stuff as
us
As me
And stuff like that and maybe even stream like in person together. That'd be fun, but yeah, I think what
And
Okay, I wouldn't be a surprised if you're getting other
So here's something
I would love comfort sleep ASMR just coming breathing heartbeat, maybe some comforting speech for me, you know, whatever
I just like the idea
Interaction so far. Yeah, I'm really looking forward to the baby. Oh
What's to come?
Yes, actually, this is something that I've always wanted to do
I think I've mentioned it in the debut where I said I wanted to do sleep ASMR
He obeyed or I either sing you a lullaby read you a bedtime story or like just
Babble to you about something and comfort you like it's okay. You could sleep. It's fine
Nina little head pad. I've had your head with some ASMR sounds of me cuddling or petting you
Things like that, you know and healthy sleep. I wanted to do things like like that
The heartbeat breathing all of that all of it. I want to do all of that comfort comfort ASMR
So I want to just bring that up so I that you all know what kind of content to expect from me
Maybe in the future
But the majority of the time is yes, I am a gamer. I am a gamer. I play a lot of games. I
Don't think I'll
Don't think I'll be
Streaming a lot of league League of Legends. Yes, I said I like league and yes
I said I like playing league, but do not expect me to play league. Um, I
Don't think I'm going to play it
So yeah
So I brought up league early, but I forgot to mention that I wasn't gonna play it
There might be a random time when like if I have free time and I have a and I do a random morning
Stream that I plan at the time or something if it's a morning stream. Oh, I probably might be bored and
Choose to stream some league just like hey, there's a random league stream if anyone wants to come you're free to come
It's fine. I understand a lot of people don't like league, but
League is my comfort game league is a game that I actually enjoy that helps me like
With racing thoughts. So I play league. I don't have to stream it. I could play it off stream
So it doesn't need to be streamed
It's just uh
A thing that I like to play and I thought that sharing my interest is better than um
Just you know, yeah
Everyone has a comfort game. I hear some people have apex legends as their comfort game
People have shooting games of their comfort game. I can have mine. Come on. Come on
Come on
League isn't that bad
I
Understand their concerns of how Lee can be a bit not comforting
Worry odds that you will do a total gen one collab like all of us collabing together
There's a high chance for that
It's pretty high
I thought we would never not do it. So all of us clubbing together. Yeah, it's pretty it's pretty high
It's pretty pretty it's pretty pretty high
Technically, yeah, technically, I'll redone one. Yeah, right. It has happened before. Yeah
It's pretty high
Um, and we have
This one's not that bad, right? It's not that bad. I'm not that bad. It's not that bad, all right
Well, mommy enjoys being a sub too, right? I'm sort of being a sub
Encouraging, you know
Though I have bad kids so sometimes
I already mentioned this before that. Yes
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, I cater to quite a lot of things and
You should expect both
So not at all
She been everyone and Emmy and everyone has been talking about what they want to do and the things that they will do
um
That's fine. I don't mind
Uh it at all. Um
I'm going to do what I like regardless
um, and that has always been my plan
And I do not mind. I'm fine with that. It's perfectly fine. Um
Besides, I think I already fit the vibes already. So I don't think that's a problem
Oh
And do I prefer mama or mommy, I think I mentioned this in a tweet
Uh, I
They both sound good
I like mama asu
But I don't mind being called mommy
so
Yeah
Yeah, I don't mind. I thought I just bring it up here
I
How do you like your coffee with lots of sugar and milk or cream
Of vanilla cream. Actually, I like it sweet. I don't like it dark
How do you call it black? Thank you for coffee. I like, uh, really sweet milky coffee
Mm-hmm. I would put like at least three
That is my alarm
For me to take my medication. Yay medication and it is also 11. So um, I believe
Marcy should be going live soon and we'll be reading it to her very soon. So
We'll gather around the campfire and get ready for our Marcy's ring
And
So I am
And then the last one was the same thing
I think had a question of the plans of the asmr content streams
Yeah, I plan to do some
Asmr's on stream live as well
So I hope you all look forward to that and look at my picture and then oh that was even the last one
Oh my current brain rot. I like cat memes lots and lots of cat memes
You know those stupid memes where they portray cats in a relationship
Those are my brain rocks
The cat memes
I
Don't know if this tech talk because I go through youtube shorts. I watch through youtube shorts and the insta shorts
Those are my those are what I watch
And then the last thing I wanted to mention was um
Was yes, we do have merch we don't have merchandise. Yay
The next one
Morton dies
Yay
Look how damn does all that's cool
So if you want to have martin dies go and get it in the in the description down below
Click the link down below for merchandise
We have the sweater and then we go back and we have the uh the sweatpants too
Yeah
I hope you like it
Hahaha
Now we have mart and we have the keychain and the um we have the keychain
It's so cute
I love it so much and the acrylics done the
Wow
I'm so close to it
Say uh, so good
Martian dies
So make sure you grab yours now, okay
Is the mercy live right now
Is the mercy live
Or is she not live yet. She's live. All right. Well, that was pretty much it for today. So
Yeah, so we're gonna call it here for today
For today
And please be assured to like and subscribe and leave a comment down below
Say bye Azura in the comments to prove that you are here and you watch this far
If you watch this far by Azura by Azura by Azura
Hahaha
Bye-bye
You